0 to 100 km per hour is the standard
test for how fast a car accelerates the
Brits call it not to 60 MPH and everyday
Road car with a bit of power can do that
in six or 7 Seconds a Formula 1 car
about 2 seconds as I record this the
fastest accelerating road legal car in
the world is the rimac NAA which can go
from 0 to 100 km per hour in 1.85
seconds this is meon built by a team
from eth zorich a Swiss University and
it hits 100 km per hour in under a
second this car is the current holder of
the world record in acceleration from 0
to 100 km per hour for electric vehicles
for the world record project we brought
together a team of alumni and current
team members some are students some are
recent graduates we took car that was
fully designed by students we modified
it that also allowed some of the members
that are still students to do research
and make a master
thesis
and I'm about to get in it and do that
but um there is quite a history of
floppy-haired British presenters getting
into high-speed vehicles and ending up
in hospital so I've got a lot of safety
briefing to do first to build a car that
can go this fast you really need to go
down to the first principles of physics
you need to be able to put enough Force
into the ground in a very short amount
of time just pure grip reaches its
limits at around 1 and 1 half seconds
approximately to get more Force into the
ground we use a self-developed system
which we call power ground effect we
suck the air out underneath the car from
a big plate and this pulls the car to
the ground to make the car accelerate
faster we use two fans that power up
shortly before launch to pull the car
down to be able to create that Under
Pressure however however for the back
wheels we need more torque so for this
we developed a new generation of Motors
that has approximately twice the amount
of torque each of the motors has
approximately the same power as a small
hatchback everything is custom
self-designed so it's quite expensive
the main source of Parts is from our
sponsors from the industry we also get a
lot of support from the University our
mission is not to build race cars it is
to build up engineers at world record
Pace a lightweight driver in here pulls
3.8 G's Peak acceleration I'm going to
add about 30 more kilos of weight so I'm
not going to quite hit that pace but
it's going to be close it's almost as
fast as the Catapult that launches
fighter jets from aircraft carriers it's
faster than any roller coaster launch
apart from one in Japan that's currently
closed because it kept shattering
people's bones there are cars which take
off faster than Mitten here but they're
Top Fuel dragsters running on
nitromethane loud enough to cause
hearing damage and not suitable for
anything other than going in a straight
line for a few seconds and and yes I
will just be going in a straight line
for a few seconds but in the Theory I
could go around an actual racetrack
electrically um the main danger is high
voltage there are um emergency buttons
push that button to turn off the car if
there is for example a fire in the car
the driver has to be able to get out
quickly it's something you have to train
and just to be quick enough that was
6.6 you have to be able to exit the car
with in 5
seconds yeah 4.6 that'll
do it's absolutely difficult to describe
because it's only a second it's a really
surreal experience because you don't
really believe it just happened you go
into acceleration mode roll to the start
initiate power ground effect which will
suck you to the floor PG
active both hands
active oh
boy you will have to pull on the buttons
behind the steering wheel and then push
throttle and then when you release there
is a split second where nothing happens
but then you will get
launched
rle
[Music]
holy what after you have reached 800 kmh
the car will shut down what and then you
can slowly on the
brakes
what that was the longest second of my
life I was that really only like one and
a bit seconds that felt like five that
was fast that felt like five seconds I
pretty much dead on 1.4 seconds 1.4 I
mean it's your Round of Applause folks
congratulations that's a heck of a
thing